-Michael, this is your
late-night-TV debut.
-This is it. This is it.
-I'm very excited. This is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's like one of things.
Like, I'm a little nervous.
But I was saying it's one of
those things that, like,
you talk about it
in acting school.
It's like, "One day,
we're going to be here."
So it's pretty --
it's pretty wild.
So thank you. Thank you.
-I'm honored to have you here
and that we're your first show.
You play Tony Soprano
in this new movie.
And before --
I want to go back to --
'cause when you were
in high school,
you did play another
iconic character.
-I did, yes. Yeah.
-In theater acting,
you were Shrek in high school.
-I was, yeah.
-And this is you.
-There you go.
-Now, that's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, yeah.
-This is prosthetics.
What do you remember about
getting in these prosthetics?
-Well, you know, I was working
with a makeup artist named Linda
and I had to convince my
history teacher to let me
out of class to be able to go
and sit in the chair
for two hours before the show.
-That's kind of amazing
for high school.
-But my school, at first,
had a very different
idea of makeup, so...
-Yeah, you brought us
a picture of what you were
originally going to be
looking like as Shrek.
Now, again,
this is a play for children.
-Yeah, it is, it is, in my
school, so --
-Here's the original makeup
test for Shrek.
-Yeah.
Yeah, that was -- Yeah. Yeah.
[ Tuba plays sad note ]
-Oh, my God!
That's frightening.
-Yeah.
Yeah, I couldn't --
I remember not being able --
They stuffed a jacket behind,
and my eyes were, like,
pushing forward, and I couldn't
see anything onstage.
And they would, like, have me
run around and sing, like,
these Shrek songs,
and I would run into walls.
-That is so scary.
-It was, yeah.
-Imagine if that
ever showed up in a window
in the middle of the night.
"Whoa!"
Gosh!
-Exactly.
-But someone saw you when
you were doing this version
and said,
"Hey, I want to work with you.
I think you got something, kid."
-Yeah, it's very true.
That play was the first thing
that got me a manager,
and then that manager
had me audition,
and now we're here, yeah.
-I want to you talk about this,
'cause I knew your dad.
He was a great guy to me.
He was so funny.
He was Tony Soprano.
-Yeah.
-I mean, that's --
And "The Sopranos to you --
did it mean anything
or you were just a kid
just playing around on set?
-I mean, yeah, the show was,
like, a jungle gym to me.
Like, that's sort of
what I knew.
I had grown up on the set,
but set to me was, you know,
being, you know,
in my dad's trailer.
And Tony Soprano
was no more than, like,
my dad eating a sandwich
in a robe.
Like, I didn't --
-That's -- Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Here's a picture of you on set
with your dad and Edie
in the background.
-Yeah.
-And look at you.
I mean, I got to --
It's got to be bizarre.
a full circle of craziness that
you're playing that role,
a younger version of what your
dad played, Tony Soprano.
-It's -- I mean,
it's incredible.
You know, full circle.
And to have gotten
to work with Vera and Jon
and Alessandro and Leslie, like,
the caliber of actors
as a young actor.
But it was surreal.
And the fact that David sort of
trusted me to play Tony,
which is one of
the greatest characters,
you know, like --
-Were you hesitant at all to go
like, "Well, look, I get it.
I understand.
But, no, I don't want to do this
because it's my dad,
and I don't want to --"
-Yeah, completely.
I thought -- Not only
because of, you know,
I want to be my own actor,
my own person,
but, also, I didn't --
I had never seen the show.
So I didn't even know
what Tony was.
I was like --
-You've never -- Really?
-No, no.
-You've never watched it?
Well, of course not.
It's not really for kids.
-Yeah, yeah. I was little.
Yeah, yeah.
So...
-You have to watch it.
It's a great show.
-No, I've seen it now.
-Oh, okay. I'm sorry.
Okay, yeah, okay.
I was like, "Wow!
Get ready, 'cause you're gonna
be blown --
Your dad was really amazing."
-I mean, that would
have been insane
just going in blind, just like,
"I don't know, we'll see."
-"I've never seen it.
Is a comedy? Let's do it."
-Yeah, no, I watched the
first season during my --
during the audition process,
and I was just like,
"I'll stay with
the first season."
And then I went on and on
and then, you know,
I became a fan of the show
like everyone else.
I just loved it.
-I think you did
such a great job.
And, I mean, you would know
better than me,
but your dad's got to be smiling
at you and so proud of you.
-Thank you.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Michael Gandolfini in
"The Many Saints of Newark."
Take a look.
-I want to go to college.
I can't get [bleep] like this.
-Hey, my friend Hess
says only goys and children
pay retail.
-This isn't wholesale.
It's totally on the arm.
-Look, you want to be
a civilian.
I appreciate that.
I'm all for it.
But pay attention to me
for once, okay?
You take the speakers, right?
At the same time,
you promise yourself,
"These speakers are it.
Now, you say to yourself,
"This is the last time
I'm ever going to steal
something," and you stick to it.
It's that simple.
-Yeah!
That's what I'm talking about.
Michael Gandolfini, everybody!
"The Many Saints of Newark"
is in theaters
and streaming on HBO Max
starting Friday.